one of the difficulties right now of
running against Donald Trump in a
Republican primary
is that if you go completely anti-maga
there may not be enough Republicans in
the party for you to win the primary but
if you go Maga in facing off against
Trump well why would somebody vote for
your Maga when the Maga guy is actually
running and this is the problem that Ron
DeSantis donors are now identifying
fascinating article in Business Insider
DeSantis Mega donors Revolt in private
chat saying if they wanted a magic
candidate they would donate to Trump
according to this report really really
interesting stuff a group of wealthy
desanctist donors criticized him in a
private chat Rolling Stone obtained
screenshots of the group chat between
Republican Mega donors earlier this week
a wealthy Florida donor publicly said
he'd changed his mind about financially
supporting DeSantis this is the latest
indication that the Florida Governor's
wealthy supporters are starting to
revolt with a republican Mega donor
recently going public about no longer
wanting to support to financially
support DeSantis has yet to be announced
campaign the screenshots reveal these
wealthy Republican donors questioning
the governor's chances of beating former
president Donald Trump in a Republican
primary they're correct to be doing that
the polling is an absolute disaster for
DeSantis lately
um a series of recent political missteps
including continuing with his
out-of-state publicity tour while
massive flooding took place in Fort
Lauderdale appear to have enraged these
donors Rolling Stone reported
responding to the Fort Lauderdale
incident the media Outlet said one donor
wrote what the f is wrong with Rd
another donor asked who in the group
could reach DeSantis the quickest to
complain about it several other donors
were Furious that the governor referred
to Russia's invasion of Ukraine as a
quote territorial dispute with one
calling on DeSantis to walk back the
comment DeSantis did later go back on
the comet after receiving criticism
um according to a rolling stone source
for familiar with the communication the
donor who called for the walk back wrote
a livid response The Source said quote
my understanding is that the message was
if we wanted an effing Mega candidate we
would donate to Donald Trump other
donors wrote they wanted DeSantis to hit
back harder at Trump with one describing
him as a damn wimp this is this is just
delightful okay so there's a couple
different things going on here yes
DeSantis has Obsessed himself with
expanding the don't say gay bill which
we will talk about on today's bonus show
the Disney stuff The anti-woke Stuff Etc
he also is alienating Florida Mega
donors by leaving Florida and selling
books in South Carolina and Chicago and
wherever else he's been while Florida is
having actual problems now the the issue
there's a couple of different issues
here to talk about
it could be argued and I believe it
could be argued
accurately that if you really want to do
something different in the Republican
party right now it's not DeSantis that
you need to turn to really it's like
Mitt Romney or even further away Liz
Cheney now I'm not saying that the
Republican party right now has enough
people in it who actually want to get
away from Naga and would go for
something like Romney or Liz Cheney I
don't know that that's the case and in
fact it very well may not be the problem
with DeSantis is that the Santas is to
Maga he frames himself as sort of like
the reasonable Maga the effective Maga
the Maga who won't get himself in
trouble because of the lack of decorum
that Trump has or whatever the case may
be but that's a really difficult
situation for Republicans because with
Trump under indictment and yet still in
a commanding lead in the Republican
primary but mostly losing to Biden in
hypothetical general election polls
which may still change
if you're Ron DeSantis you're in this
situation of well I'm going to be like
Trump but better you can't beat Trump at
Maga you just can't even if it's
accurate that DeSantis would be more
effective at Maga because he wouldn't
get himself into as many self-inflicted
problems As Trump did you can't out Maga
the Maga guy so that's not going to work
if you say I denounce Trump altogether
including trumpism and all of the things
that are wrapped up with Maga right now
at least based on the polling we're
seeing you can't actually beat Trump in
a primary right now so it's really quite
a circumstance between a rock and a hard
place you could say that the Republican
Party finds itself today and this is
what happens when you choose the rage
voters as I explained yesterday they
created anger fear voting
and they blew it up to Historic
proportions recently we didn't just find
ourselves randomly in a situation where
conservative voters are angry and also
misinformed the misinformed anger has
been a strategy for the Republican Party
once they realized they can't win on
policy anymore
and this goes back a long time you could
go back I mean if you read waves of
rancor which is a really good book maybe
out of print now you will learn about
how a lot of this started in the early
AM radio talk radio era so on and so
forth and so desantis's broader problem
is you can't out maga maga but if you
denounce Maga it's not clear you can win
the narrower problem over the last month
or two is he just won't move on he's
sticking with don't say gay he's
sticking with trans he's sticking with
Disney and he's sticking with anti-woke
Trump would have moved on to the next
thing by now and it's not like Trump's
political instincts are necessarily
Perfect by any means but Trump would
have
either by accident or by advice from
people around him or by Instinct moved
on to something new DeSantis is sticking
with these issues on which he is
actually losing not only many of the
voters but also his donors this is going
to be a fascinating campaign I love the
complete uh Crash and Burn of it and I'm
also aware that there's a strategic
component which is like who would we
rather Biden face
based on the polling we're seeing right
now
we'd rather Biden face Trump if indeed
Biden is going to run for re-election
which he says he is but has not actually
filed for at this point in time let me
know your thoughts make sure you have
subscribed to the YouTube channel at
youtube.com the davidpackman show what a
packed show that I have for you today